[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hi.
Welcome to our new
series of videos
that will bring you news
and best practices on Action
on Google.
I'm Ido Green, a developer
advocate for Action on Google.
I love to help
entrepreneurs and developers
to be more productive.
And today, we're going
to learn three design
tips that will help us build
better apps for the Google
Assistant.
Cool?
The Google Assistant
is a conversation
between the users and Google.
Users can get things done by
talking with their system.
Designing a spoken dialogue
between a human and a computer
in advance, accounting
for all possibilities
both in function
and user behavior
and still have it feel natural--
it's harder than
it looks or sounds.
The key to building a
good voice interface
is not to fall into the
trap of simply converting
a graphical user interface
into a voice user interface.
This defeats the purpose
of using a conversation.
People are not going to change
how they talk anytime soon,
so we need to take what we
know about human-to-human
conversation and apply it so
our apps can talk to humans
in a more natural way.
The top three design tips--
one, create a persona.
Two, think outside
the box, literally.
Three, remember that
in conversations, there
are no errors.
Now let's go a bit deeper
on each of these tips.
Create a persona.
It's a good way to
start your design phase
with a persona of your app.
The persona should be based
on the user population
and their needs and the imagery
and qualities associated
with your app's brand.
It's the consist characters
captured by the voice
and interactive experience.
It's the face of the
experience for the users, who
they will be talking to.
A persona is conveyed through
tone, word or phrase of choice,
style, technique, voice.
Think, for example,
about a realtor persona
or a warm friend persona.
Which persona will
be best fitted?
Think outside the
box, literally.
You should write
your core experience
like you would
write a screenplay.
This can be scrappy as acting
it out with a colleague
and documenting it on a paper or
creating an interactive Wizard
of Oz prototype.
You tweak and play until you
are ready to start coding.
And then, when you draw
out your initial version,
keep it to high level,
where the boxes represent
an entire dialogs
of user's intent,
but leave out the individual
wording you will want
to use in each interaction.
In conversations,
there are no errors.
When a problem
happens, imagine what
the users hear when your Actions
say, I don't understand you.
This is one of the greatest
cause of users' frustration
and aversions to
voice interfaces.
People get angry and
raise their voices
and repeat the same answer.
We need to give people credit
for knowing how to speak.
Just because they don't
understand a prompt or a choice
doesn't mean they don't
speak the language.
So help them be successful.
For example, rather
than asking, would you
like to hear about topic
A or B and expecting
them to say A or B,
ask them precisely,
which of these topics
do you prefer, A or B?
See, the first question is
both yes, no and either,
or question.
And remember what
happened along the way.
Maintain context.
The best way to course
correct in advance
while still maintaining
a natural, comfortable
conversation is to plan
of these occurrences
as if they were any other
turn in the conversation.
In other words,
treat them as input
that didn't cause any error.
Want to learn more?
Please see the
links here and here.
Thanks for watching.
We'd love your feedback, so
please don't be a stranger,
and leave us comments below.
Also, please make sure to
check out our other episodes.
Until next time, be strong,
and create amazing apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]